[Music]
one year ago today the city of wuhan
china was put
under lockdown as the coronavirus
continued to spread
for the next 76 days residents were
forced to stay in
while little information managed to get
out now a new documentary titled
76 days is shedding light on those early
chaotic moments
in the first hospitals to battle covet
19.
brook silva braga has an exclusive look
at the film
but a warning some of what it shows is
hard to watch
from its very first moments 76 days
is emotionally explicit
a nurse in a wuhan hospital begs to see
her dead father's body
her colleagues won't let her for fear of
contagion
director howe wu lets the ordeal play
out
for more than three minutes
why did you let it when you're so long
it was a creative choice to
let the audience experience and feel and
hear what was happening inside the
hospitals
to let them be emotionally shaken
and also moved how did you get in there
how did you get this footage
at the beginning of the lockdown there
was absolute chaos in the hospitals
and as long as a hospital chief granted
permission
to any reporter he or she can
could just really roam free inside the
hospital wu actually lives in new york
city
but last february he partnered with two
chinese journalists
embedded in wuhan hospitals huishi
chen and another anonymous photographer
each night they uploaded video for woo
to edit
it was really strange receiving footage
from wuhan in new york at that time
you know people still could go out to
eat go to restaurants
i was still meeting up with friends and
every night after coming home i would
start
reviewing the rushes from like two
cultural tents and and witnessing how
horrible
it was in wuhan almost no one in the
world
had seen footage like this in the middle
of february
that's absolutely correct we knew then
about the situation in wuhan came mostly
from images like these from chinese
state television
orderly hospitals with dancing patients
[Music]
this is what 76 days captures desperate
people
battling for a hospital bed
[Applause]
these were of course the very first
doctors and nurses in the world
to try to treat kovac 76 days portrays
them as heroes
discovering and navigating the cruelty
of the new virus
the image of the male nurse trying to
comfort an
old scared grandma who
was dying alone by herself that was
really powerful to me
but for a time wu feared none of this
footage would ever be publicly seen
as the virus spread and the chinese
government clamped down on negative
portrayals of its response
his two co-directors both chinese
citizens
stepped away from the project so for a
period of time we stopped collaborating
i was just basically sitting with this
footage and not sure whether i would be
able to
continue to make a film whether they
would let you use the footage
that yes that's right they had good
reason to worry
zhang jan a citizen journalist who
exposed bad conditions in wuhan on
social
media has since been sentenced to four
years in prison
so some viewers might be skeptical of
wu's motivation for removing
whistleblower interviews from early cuts
of the film
and avoiding political discussions in it
entirely
knowing you needed to get your
co-collaborators to agree to whatever
you made is it not fair to at least
describe this as a form of
self-censorship
the decisions you made and what to show
and what not to show i don't think so
because my co-director and i were
actually shot a lot outside the hospital
as well
we shot two whistleblower doctors it
just
didn't jive well with the other footage
we have which is
so powerful observational footage
the power comes in tiny details like
this plastic crate at the nurse's
station
filled with orphaned items that box of
phones
left over by the dead and also
especially that phone still
ringing
[Music]
31 messages unread absolutely and you
have to think what those messages are
it gives me shows even now when i think
about that image
against government regulation a nurse
collected the items
and then when the lockdown finally ended
called each
family
and returned what was left
loneliness and grief last spring that
would soon be shared
in every corner of the world for cbs
this morning saturday brooke silva
bragging
new york so interesting the decisions he
made as he put it
it's emotional yeah i mean just the
phones and returning
that that one moment you think of the
messages and people being alone we've
talked about this here we as you said
everywhere
people dying alone which they shouldn't
have done but knowing he saw this
footage before
the rest of us knew what was going to be
happening to us i mean
that in and of itself holding on to that
information
had to be torturous for him and the
heroes at the very very front line both
yeah
and here who were dealing with something
that nobody knew anything about right
at the very beginning all right today on
the one year anniversary mtv
is sponsoring digital screenings of 76
days allowing anyone to watch
for free if you want go to
76daysfilm.com i know it's tough to
watch